the great trump recovery that's the
focus of tonight's angle
only a few more shows before tuesday we
have a special one on sunday coming up
though and
i want you to have all the information
you need and won't hear anywhere else
before election day
first as the biden boosters want you
freaking out about coveted case numbers
we should instead be
celebrating tonight america's gdp number
that would not have happened were it not
for the smart decisions made by
president trump
now today's third quarter gdp report
simply put is
astounding 33.1 on an annualized basis
and remember it wasn't so long ago that
the experts
had a different gdp in mind great
depression possible the unemployment
rate is approaching great depression
levels
numbers we haven't seen since the great
depression will those jobs come back
have we gone past the r word recession
to the d word
the d word are these people ever right
no
and they never admit they were wrong
either they just do their best to
downplay
any good news that number i mean it's
gangbusters but you have to remember
it's after a record crash
don't expect that growth to last at that
pace we also got
some new unemployment numbers today that
number is trending down that's good news
but it's
still incredibly high this is the easy
part though and uh
to to christine's point you know there
are some real obstacles lying ahead
well that was the easy part they were
saying what trump did was the easy part
really
then why didn't europe replicate this
level of gdp
growth now if president trump's
stewardship of our economy was so
obvious why is it that every other
country in the g7
is doing much worse in fact the wall
street journal survey of economists
has us only down 3.6 percent for the
year
markedly better than what the imf
estimates that
every one of our european counterparts
do not forget this
chart look at it look at where we are
look at where italy is look at where
even
germany is compared to us you're not
going to see that chart
anywhere else on television now remember
these countries all stay down locked
locked down longer than we did
and they all do contact tracking and
tracing
and they all have mass mandates they
blew up their economies with these long
lockdowns
and yet their cases still exploded and
now
most of them are in the process of
locking down again
complete lunacy i mean
lord knows how bad our third quarter gdp
number would have been
if we had stayed locked down all through
the summer
like biden's experts preferred then and
now
so i think that's that in-person
schooling are likely going to
we're going to have to reconsider those
particular parts of society
right now in the midst of an out of
control pandemic yes i do certain parts
of society that are currently
open will likely have to close down for
a period of time
as this outbreak continues to worsen i
do think we're gonna have to reconsider
strategic
lockdowns anyone else find him creepy
in other words under a president biden
prepare for the economic calamity that
is happening in europe
you can run but you cannot hide from a
virus
the president understands that a free
nation of our size
cannot play with people's livelihoods
like this
we're never going to lock down again we
understood the disease
and now we're open for business joe
biden's plan is to deliver
punishing lockdowns there will be no
school
no graduations no weddings no
thanksgivings
no christmases no fourth of julys there
will be nothing
now the left here and abroad is using
the tragedy of this pandemic
to turn over political decision-making
to unelected health
experts who have zero accountability to
you
and regardless of how wrong they've been
in model after model
they want us to have no choice in the
matter whenever they
decide to put the brakes on freedom
so if your kids ask you why tuesday
matters
well tell them because our freedom
because without freedom what are we
anyway
millions of serfs waiting to receive new
rules from
nameless faceless bureaucrats always
worried that
you're going to be ratted out by
government operatics monitoring how many
cars are parked in your driveway at any
given time
that's not america that's the soviet
union circa 1977.
i'll never forget around 3 a.m or so on
election night standing about
20 feet from the stage when president
trump delivered these words
i've gotten to know our country so well
tremendous potential
it's going to be a beautiful thing every
single american
will have the opportunity to realize his
or her fullest potential the forgotten
men and women
of our country will be forgotten no
longer
forgotten not more and he meant it along
with tax cuts and deregulation he
cracked down on illegal immigration
and took on the trade abuses of china
now that part was resisted by big
business which is addicted to cheap
labor
while president trump kept his focus on
the american worker
now look at biden old joe has been
buckling under pressure to big money
interest for so long he probably doesn't
even remember his first principles
now he just does what he's told in 1973
he probably didn't
ever think he would sell out the
blue-collar workers in scranton
after being pressured by the outsourcers
i'm sure those same industries thought
they could get president trump to sell
out too
somebody went to wall street you're the
one that takes all the money from wall
street i don't take it
you have raised a lot of money
tremendous amounts of money
and every time you raise money deals are
made you know i could call the heads of
wall street the heads of
every company in america but i don't
want to do that because it puts me in a
bad position
it sure does and wall street is not
pouring money into the biden campaign
because he's going to be difficult to
influence
they're pouring money into the biden
campaign because they know he's an easy
mark
this is something you need to keep in
mind before tuesday
president trump has enormous courage
most men would have sold out long ago
just to make things
easier on themselves but he didn't
and our regular working class heroes
know it
as even democrat debbie dingle had to
concede
some of the auto workers who i thought
were going to go back to joe biden they
had were very clear with me last night
they were voting for president trump do
you want to know what the auto worker
said to me last night he said i'm tired
of your democratic friends they look
down on me
they do look down on you of course those
workers
can't write big campaign checks though
but the president
did the right thing which ended up
increasing median household income
by more than six thousand dollars
amazing
which brings us all back to joe's
running mate covid
president trump having seen what a media
superstar dr fauci had become
he could have just let fauci decide
everything from when it's safe to get on
a train to when your kid can play t-ball
again
the media would have loved that all
those daily coveted briefings
all the talk of shared sacrifice as they
headed off to the hamptons to blow off
steam on the weekend
but thank god trump knew that listening
to just
one type of expert would be
irresponsible and yes
dangerous in florida today biden claims
that the president
endangered the country by not listening
to the experts
no joe trump likely saved
us by resisting their unproven
strategies
that somehow some way always lead to
more power for them
and less freedom for us and that's the
angle